s'est aperçu au cours de la mission
d'information qu'on a pu mener avec mon
collègue jean-françois eliyahu que
l'ensemble des professionnels étaient
particulièrement désarmés dans la
gestion des dossiers individuels parce
qu'il ne disposait pas d'information
permettant d'identifier les mineurs
qu'ils étaient amenés à rencontrer dans
les différentes missions qui sont les
leurs que ce soit la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse
où que ce soit laso faute de deux
fichiers existants permettant de
déterminer leur identité leur âge
évidemment et éventuellement dans la
mesure du possible leur pays leur pays
d'origine afin de présenter le fichage
des mineurs comme finalement une
solution pour aider ce mineur alors
c'est faux c'est faux pourquoi parce que
sans ce fichage ya déjà des
accompagnements et l'aide sociale à
l'enfance et des juges des enfants qui
interviennent sont déjà là pour
accompagner les miller les mineurs et ce
qui est regrettable aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on essaye de vouloir ficher les
mineurs à des fins certainement de lutte
contre l'immigration pour plus tard
lorsque aussi mineur deviendra en
matière et non pas à des fins de
protection des enfants dix pour cent
d'entre eux seraient des délinquants
alors dans ce cas là il a besoin d'avoir
un fichage supplémentaire parce que ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que la police a
déjà des fichiers
sur la question de la prise d'empreintes
elle elle peut pas être faite de force
je crois qu'on est tous on est tous
absolument d'accord il faut trouver le
moyen de l'obtenir étant précisé que et
c'est absolument navrant mais notre
système est ainsi fait que le seul
endroit où on les emprunte quand on
arrive c'est à la maison d'arrêt et que
ça c'est pas la solution satisfaisante
et qu'on ne peut pas avoir recours à la
solution de l'incarcération pour
recueillir les empreintes je crois que
on est absolument d'accord c'est pas la
meilleure méthode éducative c'est pas la
meilleure méthode d'accompagnement et
pourtant aujourd'hui notre système fait
que ça ne fonctionne que là sauf
évidemment cas du mineur qui acceptent
volontairement de donner ses empreintes
on gagne vous expliquez que l'être en
france le premier on doit entre les
empreintes et la maison d'arrêt alors
pas du tout on prend les empreintes des
commissariats des combis interpellé la
question est de savoir que de ton faire
de ce fichage on vous dit il est hors de
question de l'imposer mais dans votre
recommande sur numéro 3 words robes
ligue à tort à la prise d'empreintes
digitales des mineurs et des prétendus
mineurs d'éléphants interpellé ne réglés
a pu accepter des prétendus mineurs
délinquants interpellés même si cette
notion juridique m'interpelle un petit
peu ils sont mineurs des rapports aux
prétendus miller des lacroix je
laisserai apprécié c'est tellement c'est
flou et c'est une méconnaissance du
droit mais de dire rendre obligatoire la
prison princeville talent des mineurs de
façon large et devenir vous présenter
que c'est dans l'intérêt mineurs dans
l'accompagnement
moi je vous dirai dans ce cas là ce que
vous devriez faire dans l'intérêt des
mineurs c'est peut-être donner les
moyens à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
parce qu'on n'en parle pas
l'un des problèmes aussi constater c'est
qu'effectivement nombre de
professionnels disque bons et il ya la
question de la détermination de la
minorité ou de la majorité nombre parle
de demi heure quand ils ne savent pas
c'est évidemment l'une des
préoccupations entre autres dans la
prise en charge et dans le placement
parce qu'il n'est pas opportun de
mélanger mineurs mineurs et majeurs et
que la prise en charge ne peut pas être
être la même à c'est un mineur il faut
que la campagne de gré ou de force
et pour l'accompagner de force il faut
qu'on sache qui sait si on sait pas on
peut voir en plus rien faire pour lui
vous avez raison on leur doit la
protection et ça on leur doit la
protection non pas parce que c'est
l'humanité qu'ils veulent parce qu'on a
un côté social ou alors doit la
protection parce qu'on a signé des
leçons
tout simplement c'est le dreams hausse
de les protéger et nous devons les
protéger et les protéger pour moi c'est
ne sait pas faire des recommandations
qui vont nécessairement dans un fichage
obligatoire mais peut-être j'aurais aimé
lire dans les recommandations davantage
de bienveillance à l'égard de ces
mineurs non accompagnés et peut-être
donner davantage de moyens dans
l'éducation et la que le mineur la
compagnie effectivement ne va pas se
retrouver délinquants